shanghai está registrando más de 2.000
casos de kobe tal día todo un récord
oficialmente no hay contención total
pero la metrópoli de 26 millones de
habitantes funciona a un ritmo más lento
cientos de residencias están selladas
vigiladas y con barricadas como aquí en
el centro de la ciudad encierros
selectivos para examinar al mayor número
posible de residentes tuvo más tenemos
que hacernos una prueba y luego tenemos
que esperar el resultado y la
notificación de las autoridades para
saber si nuestra residencia estas
bloqueadas con un jabón
pero las pequeñas empresas están
sufriendo este restaurante lleva 15 días
cerrado
mi facturación era de unos 600 a 700
euros al día y ahora que ahora no gano
nada
en todo el país se están rastreando
pacientes y contactos a través de sus
datos móviles luego son aislados durante
al menos dos semanas los hospitales se
esfuerzan por acoger a todo el mundo en
shanghai se admiten incluso sintomáticos
aquí los pacientes esperan agrupados por
cientos sin espacio para el
distanciamiento frente a las
restricciones sanitarias aumenta el
enfado en shenzhen los residentes están
en vilo en este barrio aislado durante
casi un mes
hasta esta nueva oleada china creía
haberse librado del virus así que el
regreso del covite está causando
angustia esta psicóloga ha visto
aumentar la demanda de sus consultas en
un 30%
cómo se vuelve a hablar de la epidemia
algunas personas se obsesionan con el
virus lo que puede causar pánico y
desencadenar ataques de ansiedad o una
ansiedad muy fuerte
si beijing mantiene su política de coach
pero es también porque los adultos
mayores son particularmente vulnerables
acá sólo la mitad de las personas que
sobrepasan los 80 años han recibido dos
dosis de la vacuna